when I look at a map I see opportunity
this is Patrick Quail he's a Global
Network planning executive at United
Airlines which means he decides where
the airline flies when it flies and what
type of aircraft it flies I can talk
about planes forever Quail has more than
15 years of experience planning flight
routes you can also see Denver the
aircraft flying West so he's here to
explain how that process works and how
an airline's route system affects
Travelers
two main Network structures there's Hub
and spoke and there's point to point
United and other Legacy Airlines like
Delta and American use this model the
way the Hub and spoke works you have
Denver as a hub and then you'll have
flights from let's say Lubbock
Albuquerque
Jackson Hole in Las Vegas
these are the spokes the spokes cities
all fly into the Hub the passengers then
change airplanes and then those flights
disperse to different cities across the
country here's what that looks like on a
real-time map in Los Angeles and San
Francisco you can see traffic going out
to Hawaii traffic intra California then
traffic coming up across the upper
Northeast here's what that looks like on
an aircraft schedule and the color
depicts The Hub aircraft number six for
example it's flying from Korea and every
time it's in red it's coming back to San
Francisco the spokes are designed to
feed Travelers into the Hub around the
same time to make connections easier and
more efficient but this also creates
periods of very high and very low volume
in the hub you'll look throughout the
day and it'll go Peak trough Peak trough
Peak trough and that drives cost because
you have a lot of activity you have no
activity Hub and spoke is a more
expensive model which is why Legacy
airlines are the ones who typically use
it low-cost carriers by definition try
to keep costs low in order to support
Hub you need a couple different things
one you need the assets which is the
gates the clubs the lounges the terminal
space the second you obviously need the
employees another reason Hub and spoke
is designed this way is to feed
Travelers into larger aircraft for
long-haul flights we'll have aircraft
like this 737 flying into our Hub
connecting to this large 350 seat
aircraft that's going to fly to a place
like Frankfurt or Johannesburg Quail
says that by connecting in a hub
Travelers have more options when it
comes to destinations flight times and
rebooking in case a flight gets canceled
often many hubspoke carriers have
service to multiple hubs and so if
there's a weather incident in a major
Hub we could fly you over a different
Hub and then once you get to that City
you can be re-accommodated on the
network out of that Hub if there's an
issue with the aircraft hubs also
typically have maintenance spaces we can
simply tow it to the hangar and Tow in a
different aircraft up to continue the
flight on to pay for all this
infrastructure Quail says Legacy
carriers charge a higher ticket price I
mean better product better experience
and hoping people will pay more for that
product most low-cost Airlines like
Southwest spirit and Frontier use a
point-to-point system which works like
this
you would fly from San Antonio to
Amarillo in Amarillo that aircraft might
turn and go to Kansas City and from
Kansas City it might go to St Louis and
then down to Jacksonville Southwest says
one benefit of this model is that
because planes don't have to connect
through a major Hub the airline can
offer more non-stop flight options if
you live in a smaller Community take San
Antonio for example there's a low-cost
Airline there that has 20 different
cities they serve out of San Antonio
whereas if you're flying on a legacy
carrier you're going to need to connect
in a place like Houston Dallas or
Atlanta though point-to-point carriers
don't have official hubs they do have
larger locations that facilitate many of
their connections they usually have one
Fleet type which simplifies their
operation they only have to have one
crew and one maintenance team providing
service to the exact same aircraft the
downside to this though they're only
able to serve mid-size and large cities
and they can't fly transoceanic Quail
says one of the challenges with a
point-to-point model is the ripple
effect if something goes wrong if you're
flying from San Antonio to Amarillo and
then from Amarillo to Kansas City if the
airplane has a problem in Amarillo it's
going to then impact the passengers
going to Kansas City and those
passengers getting on the plane in
Kansas City who want to fly to St Louis
and then go beyond Southwest says if a
flight is facing a lengthy delay or is
canceled between cities the airline will
bring in another aircraft or reroute
travelers to minimize disruptions but
some industry experts say the
point-to-point model may be one reason
Southwest struggled to recover from
severe winter storms last December
leading it to cancel over 16 700 flights
Southwest has held that the model wasn't
to blame according to Southwest a
point-to-point model brings in more
redundancy during weather challenges
allowing the airline to get Travelers
home as quickly as possible through
other routings
all Airlines update their route networks
throughout the year these are the
factors Quail looks for when deciding
whether or not to add a new route what's
the non-stop demand so how many people
are in the major city going to the other
City how much support is coming in from
all the different spokes into that Hub
which provide feed to that new flight
that we'd be adding if no other airline
flies to that destination that's another
reason to add that route but Quail says
he also adds service to places with a
lot of competition in London Heathrow
for example we increased service from
New York to London Heathrow to create
more time channels throughout the day
for a consumer to go between New York
and London Partnerships with other
airlines also play a role in choosing
where to fly the reason we have as many
flights as we have into Frankfurt and
Munich is for their ability to connect
onto Lufthansa to go into Eastern Europe
and North Africa to add a route Quail
says Airlines have to go through a
government regulatory process which
prevents other carriers from
piggybacking off their idea and the
process can take anywhere from a couple
months to a couple years I hope people
appreciate the complexity and all the
planning and work that goes in behind
the scenes so that when they show up the
airport they can get on a flight to go
from point A to point B and have it
operate seamlessly
[Music]
the funniest misconception people have
about me when they hear Network planning
is they think that I work in I.T
[Music]